[MUSIC PLAYING]
AKSHAY THAKKER: Please
join me in welcoming
the very wonderful and
talented Lillete Dubey.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
Please.
LILLETE DUBEY: Sitting here?
AKSHAY THAKKER: Lillete,
welcome to Google.
Have you been to Google
in the Bay Area before?
LILLETE DUBEY: No,
I haven't actually.
I haven't.
No.
I mean, I've been
to the Bay Area,
but I haven't been to Google.
[LAUGHING]
AKSHAY THAKKER: Oh,
so you're missing
the best part of the Bay Area.
Now, you are done.
This is--
LILLETE DUBEY: Now, I
have made up for it.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Now, yeah.
Well, welcome.
I am delighted to be here, like
I said, partly because you're
from Pune.
Could you tell us a
little bit about--
LILLETE DUBEY: Of
course, I have to say
that it is a very epic moment
for me to be here at Google.
Really.
And I'm not just saying that
because, today like, Durga,
you know, Durga is this
goddess with eight hands,
Google is our Durga.
You know, whatever we
need comes from Google.
So it's not just for that.
It's because today,
I was thinking
a lot about how I would
start chatting with you all.
And I thought of my father.
My father was what is
called a Renaissance man.
A da Vinci of our times
in his own way, because he
was an engineer by profession.
He was a physicist by passion.
His passion was the special
theory of relativity.
When he got married
to my mother,
he told her I have one
mistress, and that's physics.
So don't bother me, because I'm
going to spend a lot of time
with her.
And he used to get every
few years, the Britannica,
as it got updated.
And my earliest memories--
he had a fabulous library.
He was very fond of books.
So there was one sort of
room half-dedicated to books.
We used to get the Britannica.
And I thought of him today, and
I said, what an epic moment.
Dad, you will be
smiling today up
there, because I'm a Googler.
And he worked till he was 88.
He got cancer when he was 88.
And he had a computer
in his office.
But suddenly, he told
me, I want a laptop.
I said, do you even know
how to use a laptop?
He said, I'll learn it.
It's not a big deal.
And we got on to it.
And I remember Google,
because I said, Dad--
he was very low.
It was a few months
before he died.
I said, do you want to see
what you've done in your life?
Do you want to see some
of your achievements?
He said, how would I do that?
So I said, we hit Google,
and we find your name,
and we see what you've done.
And my dad gave talks
at Imperial College,
wrote for "Nature."
He gave talks at King's College,
lots of places, on physics.
So that was the last time I saw
him smile, and I saw his eyes
light up, because he saw so many
sites on which he was there.
And I remembered him
with great, great love
today, when I was
coming to Google.
I have to share that.
And the other thing
I wanted to share
was that my mother, she
was obviously not there,
because she's never printed
anything-- you know,
published anything.
And you get to Google if
you've been somewhere,
you know, on print.
I mean, that's how I
assume it's all collated.
And my mother's
feeling very left out.
And I said, how
do I cheer her up?
So I said, you
know, Mom, your dad
was the first FRCP, the
Fellow of the Royal College
of Physicians from Edinburgh.
And he also--
Sikh by religion, and
we have the holy book.
And my grandfather
also translated
the first two gospels,
let's say, of that holy book
into English.
So I said, I'm sure he's there.
So we Googled him.
And in one of the
sites that were there,
he mentioned all his
children, including my mother.
So I said, hey, you're
dead too on the internet.
And she was so thrilled.
She was so thrilled that
her father was there.
So I said before we talk
about anything else,
I have to tell you that.
Because sort of my journey in
my life, which is peculiar,
because I will tell you
about where I come from
and how sometimes
the things that you
get from your parents, which
are very strong characteristics,
also help you to break things
and do things on your own.
So I was remembering my
parents because of Google.
And I said before I talk
about anything else,
I have to thank
Google, because two
of the best moments of my
dad's life before he went
were because of Google.
AKSHAY THAKKER: That's amazing.
Thank so much for--
you know, it's stories
like these that keep
us coming to work every day.
LILLETE DUBEY: Of course.
Of course.
I mean, obviously, we
become like little babies,
dependent on that Google
Map, that Google application
for almost anything.
So that goes without
saying, but I'm
talking about a very personal
thing that touched me,
where Google really became far
more than just an application.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Yeah, that
was a very touching story.
Thank you again
for sharing that.
So you studied
English literature.
You know, a few
decades ago, how did
you convince your
parents to study
anything that didn't
sound like medicine,
or engineering, or law?
LILLETE DUBEY: Very
good questions,
because I was coming to that.
That these great parents,
wonderful, wonderful parents
that I had, were
quite unique also.
I come from a very long lineage
of academics and professionals.
OK.
So my father was an engineer,
a Lahore engineer, in college
before partition.
And my mother was a
doctor, a gynecologist,
at Lady Hardinge in Delhi.
And they were both
very independent,
strong-minded, principled,
super intelligent people.
And they didn't get
married in those days--
I'm talking about
65, 70 years ago,
till they were in their
30's, which was unheard of.
So they gave me some very strong
sort of values and good DNA
on many, many, many aspects.
But they were also very
clear that they didn't
want me to get into the arts.
So my father wanted me to be at
the least a nuclear physicist.
At the very least,
if not go into space.
And my mother wanted
me to be a path
breaking, you know, sort of a
Nobel Prize winning biologist,
or whatever.
Medicine was her field.
And it was not just her.
You see, her sister
was a doctor.
Her father was a doctor.
His father was a doctor.
And my father-- in fact, when
my father's brother studied
at Mayo in the
'50s, Mayo Clinic,
and set up the All India
Institute of Medical Sciences,
and the cousins were doctors.
So it was this deluge
of professionals.
And when I said
after school that I
don't want to do anything
any more to do with science,
I studied science
up to school, and I
said I don't have that brain.
I have a left brain.
I don't want to use that.
And my father was horrified.
You know, because, you see,
he was so well-informed.
He could talk to you
about your subject.
He could talk to my
mother about medicine,
my husband about economics,
my brother-in-law,
who's a game theorist
about game theory.
So he made everyone feel like--
that generation was a
generation of people
with a great deal of
intellectual curiosity
about-- we become a
generation of specialists.
Not me, more your
generation, which
is very important, because
depth is important,
and focus is important.
It's so competitive.
But they had a breadth
of vision, my father,
that I haven't seen very
much in recent times.
And it's quite wonderful.
In the sense of, I
remember I was reading,
Arundhati's Roy's book,
"The God of Small Things."
She just won the Booker for it.
She was sort of
a friend of mine.
And I, said you have
to read this book.
He said, well, what do you think
is so great about this book?
Why do you think she
got the Booker for it?
Or if I said, you know,
Jhumpa Lahiri got a Pulitzer.
He said, well,
what do you think?
What is the reasons?
I had given him a reason for
him to even look at the book,
because it was a waste
of time, otherwise.
He never read fiction.
And he loved technology.
He loved new things.
He loved he loved the
cosmos, reading about that.
So he felt there were so many
important things to read about,
why would you bother
reading about literature
all the time for God's
sake and study it?
So he was very, very
upset because he
could quote Shakespeare
to me better
than I could quote it to him.
And he wondered,
why the hell did
I want to waste five years of
my master's studying literature?
And he could never
understand it.
And then, you know how
Indian fathers are.
He said, OK.
Then I get a second masters
in mass communication,
just because I was scared that
theatre may not pay me any
money.
So [INAUDIBLE] luckily,
so I had a lot of offers
in advertising,
none of which I did.
He said, OK, you're
getting married now.
You're your husband's
responsibility.
I don't care what you do.
And my mother was more--
she just gave me
this very strong,
you know, at the sort of strong
matriarchal, very feisty,
independent woman
who endures this.
There were two things I
learned, one from my father,
from my mother, which
was very important to me
as a philosophy.
Because after I decided that
I was going to do theater,
I was very silly, because
when I was doing the masters,
my father said, OK, if
you must do something,
you have to excel at it.
Don't do something if you
go half-hearted, half-baked.
Go to Radha, study theater.
Or go to the NSC
and study theater.
Don't do just this sort of
dilettante-ish way of doing it.
So his philosophy was, you
will excel if you do something.
You'll have a chance to
excel only if you really
work hard and hone your skills
and put everything into it.
And my mother, one thing that
was very important to me,
was that two things.
One was that she was such
an independent-minded woman
that when I said, no, I
don't want to do this.
She said, OK, do what you want.
Do exactly what you want.
In fact, she used to
always tell me two things.
She used to tell me,
you know, in those days,
we didn't have eggs
that we could freeze.
So men, you have to get married,
because you need children.
But otherwise, it's not
that important to have
men in your life.
I'm sure she's smiling
today, because today,
women are freezing their eggs.
Just go to a sperm bank.
I want that, that, that,
and they just tick off
all their specifications.
And we're done.
That is true
empowerment, really,
aside from financial
sort of empowerment,
which to me, is the
beginning of any empowerment.
You know, in India, we talk
so much about empowerment
and women's sort of--
that they don't have
enough independence.
But it's a very
simple thing to me
that, in India,
half our population
is financially not independent.
So a woman takes
so much from a man
because she simply can't
walk out of that door.
She can't go back
to her parents,
and she has no resources,
no education, no literacy
to look after herself.
So I think before any
other kind of empowerment
that we talk about, we just
really, in India at least,
we have to talk about that,
grassroots, getting them up
there to be able to say, I
will not take this nonsense.
I will walk out of this door.
But my mother, actually, was
I think a very forward looking
woman, that she said all that.
And another thing she told
me, which was very important,
which is all connected to
my being in the theater,
was that, look, never look for
other people and other sources
of happiness.
Be the architect of
your own happiness.
Everything else is a bonus.
So if your kids love you, great.
Your husband loves, great.
If he doesn't, well, you're OK.
You're OK because you
are the wellspring
of your own happiness.
So all this sort of combined to
shape me to become what I am.
So anyway, because they were
so strong and independent,
I also could be strong
and independent.
And I said, hey, I
don't want to do this.
I don't want to be
a nuclear physicist.
But what happened was a strange
thing, which I must share,
because it will happen
to a lot of young people.
That because I did something
that I was sort of impelled
from inside me to do, I felt
that this was a calling,
the performing arts
was my calling,
but I was not able
to articulate why it
was that important right then.
And I used to feel, right
up to till I was 40, that I
was a bit of a dilettante.
My dad had this thing,
he'd come and see my plays
and say, oh, Lillete,
well done, well done,
you know, kind of thing.
But it was like, well, if
you must play at all this,
then so be it.
I started doing films.
I well recognized, and all that.
But it didn't make
any difference to him.
You know, he preferred
my theatre work anyway.
And my mother was
a great beauty,
and all her sisters
were great beauties.
But in our family, it was
like, God gave you all that.
So let's not worry
about all that.
Work on yourself.
So it was a very unusual
kind of a background.
And so I decided
to do what it did,
but it took me a long time to
be comfortable with the fact
that what I did had
a lot of meaning,
had a lot of relevance,
that it was very important.
And very often,
young people, when
they choose alternative careers,
which are not your engineer,
doctor, lawyer, computer
scientist, whatever,
the sort of general
well-acknowledged sort of life,
a serious life, earnest
kind of professions.
They feel a little like they've
disappointed their parents.
You know, I mean, today,
sport is recognized
because it's very paying.
And other professions
are recognized
because they're very paying.
But let's say 30 years ago,
these people played cricket,
but they were not
earning a lot of money.
So things have changed a lot.
But still, I see
young people who
are struggling
because this is not
the profession that their
parents would like them to do.
Not at all.
So then you have to
show your success.
And it's not easy.
A creative career is
the most difficult one
to even assess success.
You have very easy
yardsticks in other fields.
You know, a doctor has
a roaring practice,
or he earns a huge
sort of amount of money
at NYU Medical Center, or
you know Sloan, or whatever.
But how do you judge
the success of someone
in the creative world?
It's extremely difficult.
And it changes all the time.
Today, you're God, you have
three films that are bomb,
and you're out of there.
You're nobody.
So it's such an elusive,
ephemeral kind of success
that we're talking about.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Well,
and these days, it
sounds like the number
of YouTube followers
and Twitter followers you have
is a good measure of success
as well.
LILLETE DUBEY: I
didn't even know I o.
AKSHAY THAKKER:
But to your point,
it does change over time.
LILLETE DUBEY: Yes, yes, yes.
AKSHAY THAKKER: You
did a lot of work,
obviously, in Bollywood in
the arena, but also in the UK
and in Hollywood.
How do you compare
the two experiences?
LILLETE DUBEY: It's very simple.
My heart, my soul, my body,
belongs to the theater.
I'm a dyed in the
wool theatre person.
And it's weird, because if you
meet a theater person, when
I was doing "Marigold, I
met Judi Dench and Maggie
Smith, who are died in the
wool, 60 years with the National
Theater in London.
So there is an
immediate connect.
It's a different kind of
binding, bonding, that happens.
So my heart, everything
belongs to theatre.
Because for me,
theater's where it's at.
It's the last pure bastion left.
It is still relatively
untainted by commerce.
Now, I tell you a little
bit about my theater work,
because it's important
in the light of all
the questions you'll ask.
I worked as an actress
for 15 years, like a diva,
doing all the lead roles with
a person called Barry John,
and had a whale of a time.
And then I started
to decide to set up
my own company 27 years ago.
So now you know exactly,
like a fossil, how old I am.
And I decided I want to
do that for two reasons.
Also, like I told you, there
was this slow understanding,
why are the performing arts and,
therefore, theater important?
Why are they important?
What does art bring to us?
What is so important about art?
And it was like
an epiphany at 40
for me, that you know, really,
art is what illuminates life.
It's what Shakespeare says.
It's a mirror up to nature.
We all live.
We live a wonderful life.
There are, of course,
Eureka moments--
a mathematician proves a theorem
which hasn't been proved,
or a problem that hasn't been
proved for 50 years, or 30
years, and wow.
It's a Eureka moment.
A runner breaks that
marathon record.
You know, there are Eureka
moments in every field.
But for me, I feel that,
as a whole, the whole body
of the performing arts, and arts
as a whole, including painting,
music, all that, these are the
things that really originalize,
illuminate our lives, you know,
expand our horizons in ways,
which to me, if you ask me what
is divinity, it is the arts.
When we hear a wonderful piece
of music, when we see and read
an astounding poem.
You know, we come closer to
something which is beyond us.
So to me, it's really
spiritual almost.
And it's something that
absolutely opens up
dimensions in our mind, which
we don't even know exist.
So I realize the value of it.
And more than that,
the value of--
you know, we live in
a technological age.
OK, we're going more and
more into that little screen
for everything.
Jug Saraiya, this wonderful
columnist in India,
once wrote that,
"Many, many years ago,
that soon, there will
be one small little room
with a small little man with a
small little smartphone sitting
in a corner getting sex, food,
clothes, whatever he wants,
you know, in that
small little room."
In a way, it's funny.
In a way, it's scary.
Because the human experience
is getting so contracted.
So contracted.
And a weird thing's happening.
As much as we are looking for
that sort of the virtual world
in which we live, and the
digital world in which we live,
we also crave--
because are ultimately
fireside storytellers.
This is our DNA as well.
So how do we connect
to each other?
Our common humanity is
through shared experience.
Why do I love theater?
Because it's not complete.
If he's not there and I'm
not there, I could be here.
It's not complete.
He's there.
We need those two
people to connect.
So it's not just theater.
It's music.
It's dance.
But specially theater,
especially theatre.
I can still dance.
You see, for
myself, I can dance.
I can sing for myself.
I can paint for myself.
But can I perform for myself?
No, I cannot.
It has to be you with me
in that shared experience.
And that's the beginning
of our common humanity.
That's how we start
connecting with each other.
You know?
And we tell stories, which are
universal, let me tell you.
When I did a play called
"Dance Like a Man,"
in New York, the same one
that ran Off-Broadway,
"The New York Times" had
never covered an Indian play.
And my raison d'etre with
starting a company was I
wanted to talk about the Indian
voice, Indian English voice,
original voice,
in Indian theater.
Why in English?
Because then, he can
understand my plays.
He can understand.
He can listen to the
stories, the plays,
that have been written
by our playwrights.
Very often people have asked me
to come, including in America,
why don't you come
in direct to play?
I said, but then, who
will tell our stories?
You have plenty of people
to tell your stories.
We don't have anyone.
We have a handful of
people to tell our stories.
They need us to
tell our stories,
to tell a [NON-ENGLISH]
play, put it out there,
or [NON-ENGLISH],, or
zillions of very talented--
I remember I did a play once,
and this very, very, very
well-known group from America
came and, this woman said, wow,
that was fabulous.
Who's written the play?
So I said this guy
called Mahesh Elkunchwar.
He's Indian?
I said, but it's so--
fantastic.
I said, you know, I
don't know if that's
a compliment or an insult?
Because the way you're
asking me, it's like, oh,
an Indian couldn't
have written that play.
She's like, no, I really
mean it's so sophisticated.
I don't think anybody--
so I said, thank you.
You're just putting your foot
in your mouth again, and again,
and again.
You know?
Just stop.
So I realized that's it.
We have to-- so we are,
without being too immodest,
the most traveled
company in India.
We've done 3,000 shows in
India and abroad, right
from Wellington, New Zealand
to Portland, Seattle.
And all through most
of the countries.
I haven't been to China yet.
I haven't been to Russia yet.
I haven't been to
South America yet.
A few continents left.
But plenty have been taken to.
And let me tell you the
most interesting thing.
So I did it because not just
that I wanted to platform
Indian work, but I
wanted to see-- you know,
the Indians have a habit.
And I don't mean this badly, of
patting ourselves on the back
and saying, fabulous,
that was wonderful.
Especially you go to
see a movie premiere,
they're so hypocritical.
Everything's mind-blowing, and
then they walk out of the room
and say, oh, god,
it was terrible.
So you know?
But Indians do that.
They sort of buck each other up.
And they don't really
tell you the truth.
So when you take an Indian play
outside and do it out there
in Kuala Lumpur, or in Bangkok,
no one's going to be generous.
If it's good, it's good.
If it's bad, it's awful.
So to take a play
about [INAUDIBLE]----
now, [INAUDIBLE] you know, we
have a caste system in India,
which is horrible,
which is still
sort of still in the
fabric of our lives,
which is awful absolutely.
So there were you know
the very, very educated,
the less educated, the
warriors, and then the people
who clean your houses, and there
were always the untouchables.
And Gandhi fought against.
And so, it's a story about them.
It's like, a black guy from
Harlem, very, very dirt poor,
marrying an Upper West
Side rich, rich white girl.
You know?
So for me, that
story was about that.
It was about culture clash.
You know?
And however liberal
we are, you just
have to scratch the surface.
And then if your daughter is
marrying someone like that--
[INAUDIBLE] intellectuals,
armchair intellectuals saying,
of course, we must integrate.
We must do this, and all that.
And then when it comes
into your own living room,
you can't handle it
So I was shocked that the play
like this could touch people
in Kuala Lumpur, could touch--
the subcontinent's OK.
They understand all
these references.
But for it to work in a Kuala
Lumpur, or a place like London,
where non-Indians were
seeing it, but they got it.
They got all that.
It didn't have to be--
and I don't peddle it
in a sort of sweetened way.
We talk as we talk.
If I'm Gujarati, I talk
like a [NON-ENGLISH]
or a [NON-ENGLISH].
And if I'm a South
Indian, I talk like that.
I mean, clear, but
with an accent.
And people said, oh, you
can't do plays like this.
Nobody will understand.
I said, hell, I come to America.
I go hear James Earl Jones doing
"Fences" with a Harlem accent,
and I have to say,
hello, what was that,
what was that, what was that?
I didn't understand
half the play.
But I still loved
the experience.
So we have to
enter those worlds.
We're not going to give
it to you on a platter.
Come, I will explain what
this means and that means.
No, no, no.
We're going to explain nothing.
You come here, you
enter our world.
And then you see the
universality of the stories.
Because like the
"Natyashastra," which
is a great book,
5,000 year old book
that talks about the
performing arts--
I don't think there's an
older book than that--
talks about the
seven emotions only
that human beings go through,
the nine [INAUDIBLE],,
so the dance, then
music, then theater.
And I was shocked.
I knew why "The New York
Times" is so respected,
because when we
performed there, they
gave us a half page
review on their Arts Page
on a Friday arts review.
It's like a Bible.
So I didn't know that they
came quietly, they saw it,
they quietly wrote this
review, and it came out.
And my friends in the
theater and in New York
said, my god, you've been
performing for 20 years,
and "The New York
Times" never covered us.
So they covered us, and
what was very interesting
was, I believe it was a very
tough critique, and all that.
And he gave us a
glowing reviews.
But that's not the point.
At the end of it, he
quoted the "Natyashastra."
And I said, my god,
this old white guy,
who was like 70 years old, he
really has done his homework.
And he's gone to
the "Natyashastra,"
and he gave us the
biggest compliment
I've ever got, because he
said, "The lofty ideals
of the "Natyashastra" may
be very difficult for humans
to achieve, but this play
comes pretty damn close."
And I thought that was such
a marvelous compliment.
And another one important
wrote about how,
you know, you enter this
play, and you think,
oh silk saris, and Indian
music, and flowers in the hair,
and about classical
[INAUDIBLE] dances.
And are we going
to get any of this?
And at the end of the
play, you say, my god, this
is as familiar to me, this
story with its relationships,
and its conflicts, and its
everything, as my kitchen sink.
So that is the idea, that we
open doors of understanding,
we celebrate our
differences, but we
open doors of understanding.
And in that, art has
such a huge role to play.
Such a huge.
Role sports does, but sports
is more in that arena of,
you know, at some point, we
get a little nationalistic.
OK?
Let's admit it.
In art, you don't get like that.
If there's some
wonderful singer--
I heard a fabulous band called
[INAUDIBLE] from Algeria.
The desert music, the
Grammy award winner.
They just held them
recently in Mumbai.
It didn't matter I didn't
understand their language.
I didn't understand their--
I understood nothing of the
reference or the context.
But I said, wow, what music.
So it elevates us.
It takes us somewhere else.
It celebrates all
the differences.
But it just brings
us all together
in such an amazing
way, that I realize,
that's why I love the arts.
That's why I want
to be where I am.
And my theater especially,
not just Indian,
it's also about
exploring subjects.
Again, film is so
determined by commerce
that, unless it's a very small,
very independent film that
is exploring something
very explosive, in theater,
you can do that.
You can do that.
I mean, my plays go
from sexual abuse
to the first main screenplay on
homosexuality, which is still
a punishable offense in India.
Can you believe it?
How archaic is that?
To Gandhi's
philosophy, and how did
Gandhi had these
out of the box--
we talk about out
of the box ideas.
Each and every idea of
Gandhi's was out of the box,
[NON-ENGLISH],,
nonviolence, [NON-ENGLISH]..
Everything, if you examine,
it's a brilliant play,
it's got many awards.
And when you see an Arab
sitting after the play
and talking to me about Gandhi,
and it is so fascinating,
and you think this
is a country--
what would this Arab
know about Gandhi?
But he's fascinated.
It's fascinating,
because the play
was a play that explored Gandhi,
was sort of the common jewel.
And there was the Mahatma.
And there were these
debates between them.
You know?
And through that, he said,
you know, you could do this.
He said, I can't do that.
I'm just an ordinary fellow.
How can I do all this.
He said, why?
One person can
make a difference.
He said, oh, don't
talk nonsense.
One person can do anything.
And that's how he said, be
the change you want to be.
Because one person can do it.
Two people, what are their
names, who started Google?
Two guys sat together.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Yeah,
Larry Page and Sergey Brin.
LILLETE DUBEY: Yeah,
they just sat together
one day, two PhD students
and said, hey, let's do this.
And that's all it is.
And you guys know it
better than anybody.
It's just an idea,
the germ of an idea.
So to have an Arab
talking about Gandhi
was very strange, with all
their robes and all this out,
and they discussed it
after the play in Dubai
and in Moscow, they used
to talk about Gandhi.
So it could be
Gandhi's philosophy.
It could be Zen Buddhism.
I've done a play on
Buddhism, because you
know zen comes from Dhyana,
and Dhyana is meditation.
And it's founded by [INAUDIBLE]
King, who was so weak,
he couldn't breathe.
The King was going
to throw him away.
The King was this wrestler
and, you know, very macho,
and all that.
And he has this little
weakling of a prince who's
puffing away because
he's a blue baby,
and he says, just chuck him.
We don't need him.
And the Brahmin, who did
the [INAUDIBLE] for him,
says, no, I'll keep it.
And he teaches him yoga.
And he teaches him how to read,
and he teaches him exercises,
so that he learns and he
creates the martial arts
and becomes a 28 sort of sort
of high priest of Buddhism,
goes there to China,
and they couldn't
pronounce Dhyana, so it became,
tian, chan, john, zane, zan.
Bu tthe time it hit
Japan, it was zen.
You know?
And I was so fascinated,
because I said.
This is from India.
Nobody even knows this.
And then we did it in Hong
Kong, Singapore, Bangkok,
that whole belt over there.
And people were fascinated.
And I said, hello, it
all comes from here.
I, mean I'm sorry, but what
can I do if everything just
started in India?
The zero came from here.
This came from there.
So the subjects I choose
are very eclectic.
You know, now, "Gauhar," when
I was doing "Gauhar," everyone
said, a woman in 1902 singing
some old classical Indian
music, I mean, OK.
So she was the one that sang
first on a vinyl record.
So she made history.
And she was like an Amy
Winehouse of her times,
without the drugs, I think.
Maybe she was doing
opium on the side.
Who knows?
But she sang.
She composed.
She wrote her own lyrics at 15.
She sang in 20 languages.
She was on, you know,
like little matchboxes.
And whatever kind of publicity
they had all over Europe,
she was huge.
She was a rock star of her time.
And people had
been uninterested.
They said, well, who was
interested in this thing?
And it's been such
a huge success.
Because, of course,
people are interested.
Why wouldn't they be?
My job is to make them
interested, if I'm interested.
Then I have to make you-- engage
you-- to get you interested
in what I'm seeing, and why
I feel it's important for you
to know this.
So it has-- it's the kind of
work one does, also, is like--
and the chance for me
to be part of theater.
You know, the play on
sexual abuse was, I think,
particularly moving
because it was
commissioned by
an NGO that works
with survivors of sexual abuse.
And when we did
it, we had people
after every show
coming and crying
because their own stories
came back to them,
which were very suppressed.
But more than that, men came
to me and said, you know,
I don't think I'll ever
leave a daughter of mine
alone with a male
servant ever in my life.
Even for like half an hour,
because he was so scared.
And then people said,
why only a young girl?
Even a young boy
can be molested.
So I would not leave
any of my children
alone with somebody I
didn't trust at all.
So it has a very--
I don't do only
that kind of work.
But really, if you use
it as a tool of change,
it has enormous power, enormous
power, to transform things.
And the best theater, which I
hope mine does to some extent,
is that it must make you
look at the world anew.
To examine things
anew, provoke you
to think about things
in a different way,
to re-examine things, to
understand the world anew.
And the best theatre
does do that.
The best writing does do that.
Art can do that.
So then I started realizing the
power of the performing arts.
I mean, they're limitless,
as your field is
limitless in where it can go.
You know, maybe none
of us will exist.
They'll just be two
AI sort of types
sitting over here and talking.
But whatever, whatever.
You know?
So to me, it's that infinite
possibilities of what theatre
can do, what the stage
can be a crucible for.
That is very, very exciting.
AKSHAY THAKKER: So you made a
really good point about theatre
being a tool to tell stories.
And you've certainly taken
that across the world.
And here in the Western world,
we have a very strong theatre
culture, very strong
theater scene, you know,
the likes of "The
Book of Mormon."
Very common name.
LILLETE DUBEY: Well,
I wouldn't use that
as my top of the list example.
[LAUGHING]
AKSHAY THAKKER: Well, my point
is, these are very common names
that a lot of people know.
Now, theatre in India has a
very-- almost a cult following.
People follow it, and
then most of the country
doesn't actually follow it.
Are you seeing this change?
Are you--
LILLETE DUBEY: What do you mean?
AKSHAY THAKKER: Most people,
when you grow up and going
through India, you don't really
go to theatre or watch plays.
That's not a thing
most people do.
LILLETE DUBEY: Because
theatre's never been a--
AKSHAY THAKKER: Right.
And this is my question to you.
LILLETE DUBEY: --habit.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Right.
This is my question to you.
Are you seeing this
change in India?
Is this culture growing,
or is [INAUDIBLE]??
LILLETE DUBEY: Yes, yes, yes.
The thing, I think,
firstly, we have
a very strong tradition of
what I call the folk theater.
It's very alive
and very kicking,
and it's very much there.
But we're talking about a
more urban kind of theater.
So that kind of theater
is definitely growing.
And in some languages-- you
know, India's so diverse.
I don't know any other
country as diverse as that.
I mean, 37 languages,
dialects, god
knows how many
whatever, whatever.
So I mean, I can't even
count the number of--
I go down south in
India, and I sometimes
feel I'm in an alien
country, really,
sometimes, because
it's so diametrically
different, the culture.
And so what I was saying
was that in some states,
like Gujarat, like
Maharashtra, like let's
say, Canada, Bangalore.
In some languages, it's
a thriving culture,
theater scene, where theater is
done, like Marathi theater, 30
plays a month, sometimes 35.
Double ones on
weekends and all that.
And it's commercially viable,
and people live by theater.
Gujurati is a very
commercial theater.
So it's the Hindi and English
theater which is not so--
you know, but in a
place like Bombay,
because they have
access, like in New York,
they can do so
many other things.
They don't only
have to do theater.
They can be on television.
They can do commercials.
They can host events.
They can a voicing.
They can do films.
They can do web series.
So they're are working actors.
They can do lots
of other things.
But yes, it is not like--
but let me tell you,
in America also,
it's only the big Broadway
shows that an actor can actually
live on.
If he's doing smaller
theaters, no way.
He has to do other stuff.
He has to.
It's just that in
a Broadway gig,
he's sure of income for a
year, or so many months,
or whatever, whatever.
But then, again, he's out
there auditioning, auditioning,
auditioning, hoping to
get that next good gig.
So it's one of the most
uncertain businesses
in the world, being an actor.
Let me tell you.
[LAUGHING]
AKSHAY THAKKER:
So you were here--
LILLETE DUBEY: But
things are changing,
which is what I was coming to.
A lot of young people are very
interested in doing theater.
And one of the things we did
do, and I will say it again,
a little immodestly, is
we were the first to start
working with Indian writing.
So once that door opened,
you see we always did,
especially theatre in,
English, which is derivative.
We did a Tennessee Williams,
an Arthur Miller, a Neil Simon,
or of course Shakespeare
and Brecht, from you know,
whatever, whatever, so
many wonderful playwrights
in the West.
And people keep saying,
why don't you do them?
I said, because the whole
world is there to do them.
I have to do my stuff.
Once in a blue moon, I get
seduced by a fabulous script,
and I do it.
But that's like, one-off.
You know.
Or I feel it's so
universal, like I'm
doing a play, which
is about the Iraq war,
about survivors of the Iraq
war between the two Gulf wars.
And it's just such a
potent piece of theater.
And it's a one woman show,
which my daughter does.
And she's incredible in it.
It's about survival.
It's about violence.
It's about the times we live.
And so it doesn't matter.
It could be Iraq.
It could be Timbuktu.
It could be Bombay.
We've had terrorist
attacks there.
We're having them
all over the world.
So how to survive in
an age of violence.
And women-- because
you see women
aren't the ones
who perpetrate it,
but they are the ones
who live with it.
Men go out there
to do their stuff,
to prove themselves, in whatever
way they think they have to.
But the women pay the price.
So these are the stories
of women survivors,
and how they deal with
a 8-year-old child who
plays with bullets,
makes chains out of them,
and is very proud of
her little M16 bullets.
Two women, somebody
in exile who's
staying in London, who's very
upset about what's going on,
but can't go then handle it,
to a painter who compromises,
who does what she has to
do, but she has to paint.
So she doesn't care.
So you know, those
stories are so universal,
that all geographical,
social cultural references
become absolutely irrelevant.
Then sometimes I do them.
But yeah, theater
in Bombay at least,
it's growing exponentially.
But we can never compare it to
film, television, and all that.
You know?
That's our mistake.
We keep comparing it.
It's a niche medium.
A play of mine, like
"Dance Like a Man,"
that I've done 600 shows
of, you multiply that even
by 1,000 people per
show, how many is that?
Yeah, that's not very many.
But movies reach
millions of people.
In one weekend,
somebody will see
a movie of mine, which is
at least 100 times that.
So how can you compare the two.
But look at the freedom you have
artistically, creatively, when
you do work in the theater.
You can do that sort of
work in film as an actor,
or as a director-producer.
AKSHAY THAKKER: So two
of your cast members,
Rajeshwari Sachdev and Zila.
LILLETE DUBEY: Are
very much here.
Three of them are here
from the play "Gauhar."
AKSHAY THAKKER: Wonderful,
they're in the crowd.
Could you tell us a
little bit about how
you decided to cast
them, and that I'd
like to bring up on stage
chat with them a little bit.
LILLETE DUBEY: Yes.
Very much.
So I was looking--
you know, in India,
we don't have
a concept of training
in musical theater,
because that needs
special skills.
You need to be an actor.
You need to be a good singer.
You need to be
preferably a good dancer,
and have enormous
stage presence.
And that's all, all
rolled into one.
Nothing much.
So since we don't have
trained actors like that,
it's particularly
difficult in India.
Abroad, they go to
drama school, they
specialize in musical theater.
So it's much easier.
But that didn't dawn
to me, of course.
And the play was written,
actually, not as a musical.
I had done musicals.
This was written
as a play, which
is a drama about her life.
And we have to
Gauhar, the younger,
up to a certain age, and
then the older Gauhar.
And so, Mahesh, who
adapted it, it's
from a wonderful book, which
is researched for five years
by Vikram Sampath on his own
steam at his own expense,
because he was
fascinated by her.
I think he was half in love
with this girl [INAUDIBLE]..
And he wrote the book.
Then I liked the book very much.
I asked a very very
eminent playwright of our,
who was assigned Academy winner,
Mahesh Dattani to write it
as a play.
And then there was
this triumvirate talks
going on, you know,
about, I want this,
no, I want that, no,
I don't want that,
and all that sort of thing.
So finally, we got
the script together.
And he said, we'll
just play her music.
Now this is, again,
thanks to Google.
So how do we find her music?
Because she sang in 1902.
And so we Googled her, we went
to YouTube, and found her.
And I said, oh, my god.
Because it was a very
primitive recording.
[INAUDIBLE] records, the
very first records ever made.
And she did something, and she
was a fabulously fascinating
woman on many counts.
I won't go into that.
But she took up the gauntlet--
she picked up the gauntlet.
Because an Indian [INAUDIBLE]
can go on for three hours.
It's just this one phrase,
which you just keep singing,
and it's like jazz.
You keep improving,
improving, improving.
And the more of a
virtuoso you are,
the more you will improv
to show your skills.
Because there's just
the seven notes,
and you're doing all
kinds of things with them.
So she had to do that in
two and and a half minutes.
She had to do the prelude,
the central section,
and the climax.
And all the purests turned
up their noses and said,
this is blasphemy.
You can't do this sort of thing.
And she said, show me the money.
So they paid us, in those days,
I don't know what it would be.
3,000 rupees a
recording in 1902.
What would that be today?
I don't know.
How many thousands of dollars?
AKSHAY THAKKER: Google it.
LILLETE DUBEY: Huh?
Google it.
[LAUGHING] So anyway, some
obscene amount of money.
And she said, can be done.
And even her mother
said, what are you doing?
Our gurus will be very shocked.
You can't do this sort of thing.
So she said, I have to try it.
I'm going to try it.
And so that's why
she was the first.
Everybody followed suit later.
But she said, I will do it.
So she was a path breaker.
I think it's an appropriate
thing that I found her
on the net through Google,
and I'm sitting here
talking about her,
and she, like Google,
was someone who loved new ideas.
You know?
She kept telling her mother,
they had all these patrons,
these maharajas,
and all, you know,
who used to call them
for concerts and things.
And she said the
patrons of the new world
at the mouths of the New World
would find us our patrons.
So we don't have to worry
about these maharajas anymore.
This is technology.
This is what's going to live.
You know?
And she says that.
There's a moving moment at the
end of the play when she says,
you know, I went to hear
a concert, and I said,
this is my music.
This guy is singing my song.
And I told everybody,
and they said,
ha ha, this crazy old lady.
This biddy, how can
this be her music?
And she said, it doesn't matter.
My name also will be
forgotten, but my music
will live on that record.
And it will always be there.
And that is why
we're here today.
Because our music lessons.
And we can access it
through technology.
So much as I am a great
believer in the human touch,
and I'm really old-fashioned--
I still prefer smelling
a book, feeling the page,
all that with my coffee.
I'm not a Kindle person.
But having said
that, technology can
be used very creatively
in the arts as well.
You know?
It should not
become a substitute,
and it shouldn't become
packaging or gimmicky,
but it can add a lot.
We've seen it in
so many industries.
I mean, the music industry,
and this, and that.
It brings a lot.
And it also reflects our times.
These are our times.
These are technological times.
So even our art should--
you don't, I have a
friend [INAUDIBLE]..
Her husband is doing paintings
on a smartphone with a stylus.
And he's doing
these exhibitions,
and they're selling out.
They're selling
out his paintings.
They not be expensive, but
it's a new way to paint. .
And it's still art.
So, it's wonderful.
I mean, there's
the installations.
There's visual art.
There's so much use of
technology now in the arts.
But as long as we don't
lose the human connect.
That's all that's important.
So I had a bit of a problem
because I said, now,
what I going to do?
I need two wonderful--
I mean, I need a wonderful
cast, because there
are many other wonderful
actors in the play.
But we need two wonderful
"Gauhars" who can sing,
who can act.
So the younger one was
Rajeshwari Sachdev,
who is very talented
actress, who
also has cut albums and sung.
And she's a very nice
[NON-ENGLISH] dancer,
though she's doing
[NON-ENGLISH] in the play.
And she's a very fine actress.
National award- winning actress.
So I sort of zoned into her, and
I said, she's the one I want,
and she was also very
thrilled with the box.
Now there was the
older "Gauhar."
And the play wasn't conceived
with music, but I decided no.
When I heard those
YouTube scratchy recording
and this nasal voice,
I said, my God,
we're doing her a disservice
if we played this.
People will say,
well, why are they
doing a play about a woman
who sounded God-awful.
So we're not going to do that.
If we're going to
present, we're going
to present her the
best that she could be,
as she must have
sounded when she
sang like this at
the [INAUDIBLE]
concert or something.
So that made my job
even more difficult,
and then I decided I
want live musicians.
And one of the instruments of
that period was [NON-ENGLISH],,
which is kind of--
what would you say?
Kind of violin at that time.
So there's very few people who
are playing that instrument
anymore, and a [INAUDIBLE]
player, and a harmonium player,
and all that.
And musicians are their
own sort of divas.
So they say, yeah,
today, [INAUDIBLE] come.
OK.
Tomorrow, maybe we can come,
and all that sort of thing.
So I pulled out a wild
card for the second one.
I had heard her sing, and
she has a magnificent voice.
Really magnificent.
She's a great
[INAUDIBLE] daughter,
who learned music at
her father's knee,
where she went at eight
and said she was very
depressed and extremely sad.
And he said, why is
that, my darling?
And she said, because
nobody's teaching me music
because she was a
girl, and all the boys
were being taught music.
So he said, all right.
We can fix that.
So she started
learning from him.
And she's a Sufi
singer, and she sings
in many, many sort of styles.
So I'd heard her sing, and I
thought, what a fabulous voice
she has.
And I know she hadn't acted.
I mean, she did something very
small long, long back on stage,
but she has enormous stage
presence, lovely voice,
and lovely speaking
voice as well.
And I said, you know what?
What I'm going to take her.
And everyone, oh, she
has a fabulous voice,
but are you sure you want
to take her as an actor?
I said, I want to
take her as an actor.
And she's done a marvelous job.
I mean, she sings, and
it blows your socks off.
But that aside, she's done a
lovely job of the play as well.
So we have these two Gauhars.
And then, we have Danny Sura,
who plays multiple parts.
He's an actor who
moved from London.
He's a trained actor from
London who moved to India.
And he plays many,
many roles in the play.
And we have four other actors.
We have two young actresses
who are from here,
from the Bay Area,
who have small roles,
which we case here,
[? Sukanya ?] and [? Sandra, ?]
the two beauties
sitting next to Danny.
And then we have
another person called
Rajiv, who's coming in
tomorrow, and Denzil Smith, who
plays the father of Gauhar
when she was young and also
[? Gainsbourg, ?] the American
Anglo-phile sort of engineer
who went-- he was American,
but he stayed in England,
so he was more Brit
than an American.
And he went to look
for the big star
for the gramophone
company, who would
sing for the first time
on the vinyl record.
So there was a
great opera singer
who sang at the same
time that Gauhar sang.
So they both sang in
different parts of the world
and cut a record
at the same time.
And he comes down.
I was hoping he'd
be here because he
has a little lovely speech when
he tells us about how he landed
here, and how that
one record changed
the history of
Indian music forever,
that record that she sang, the
first record that she sang.
So it's sort of
connected to technology.
I was thinking
about it last night,
and I said, how
appropriate that I'm
coming to Google with Gauhar
and talking about Gauhar,
which, actually, at
its base, the play
has the historical
importance of technology.
Really.
So that was quite
serendipitous, I think.
[LAUGHING]
AKSHAY THAKKER: Let's
invite them on stage.
LILLETE DUBEY: Rajeshwari
Sachdev and Zila Khan.
[APPLAUSE]
LILLETE DUBEY: Come on them.
Hi, everyone.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Hello.
So Rajeshwari, you play the
younger Gauhar in the play.
How do you balance sort of
adding your own creative touch
to his character, while still
being true to the real person?
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: Oh,
what a difficult question.
As an actor, it is our job
to understand the part,
and that only comes with a lot
of study about the character
that you're doing and
she, unfortunately,
is not in front of us.
I'm sorry about my voice.
A bad case of laryngitis.
LILLETE DUBEY: But it will
fine by Saturday and Sunday.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: It will
be fine by Saturday, Sunday.
Yes.
You have to study your part.
It's very good if you have
a living character to play,
so you can see the person.
But we were very fortunate that
Vikram Sampah wrote a book,
"My Name Is Gauhar Jaan."
LILLETE DUBEY:
Meticulously researched.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV:
Every little part.
He tried to piece
together all her letters,
and what her life
would have been,
and the society of those times.
It's so well-explained,
so detailed,
that it was a cakewalk
after that honestly,
because it is all
on a platter for us.
LILLETE DUBEY: But also, I
think it's interesting when
[INAUDIBLE] is not there,
it also gives you that space
to fill those that--
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: That
also works in the script
because, obviously, you
can't put the whole book
in a two-hour play.
Now, to get that message
across to the audience-- now,
I have the read book, so I
know where it comes from, what
we have derived, from where.
But when as an actor,
I'm piecing together
bits of our life,
there's a lot that I'm
bringing to that one scene,
which the audience is not
fully aware of, because
there's a study that's gone.
So that's interesting, trying
to put things in between lines,
in those moments,
and those pauses,
trying to add that extra.
That's always an exciting
journey for an actor.
And I think that's process we
have in every part that we do.
AKSHAY THAKKER: A lot of us
here in the crowd grew up
in the indie pop era, and
listening to your work
was just natural for us.
So I know you're recovering
from a throat issue.
So if you're
comfortable with this,
and if you don't mind singing
us one line of [INAUDIBLE],,
it would be lovely.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: My god.
Should I try that?
OK.
I have to take my
director's punishment,
because she's asked me to keep
my mouth shut till my show.
Save you voice.
LILLETE DUBEY: Not that she's
doing anything of the kind.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV:
No, I am, I am, I am.
[INAUDIBLE] I would
have measured it out.
But I can try.
Maybe I cannot really belt it.
LILLETE DUBEY: Just
a couple of lines.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
LILLETE DUBEY: Lovely.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Thank you.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: Thank you.
LILLETE DUBEY: I'm going
to make them sing anyway.
She's going to sing less,
because she's done her bit.
AKSHAY THAKKER:
[INAUDIBLE],, you've
obviously been singing for
a long time in your life.
How did you prepare for
this role portraying
a character who has--
ZILA KHAN: Lillete helped me.
Every step of the
way, she helped me,
and she helped me open those
sometimes painful, sometimes
lovely visuals in your life that
that women and men go through.
And then she opened--
and she made it so easy.
She is a fantastic
director, because--
and I'm not just saying
it here, because it
was very difficult for me.
Singing my concerts,
which I always do,
is a different skill set, as
Lillete had already mentioned.
And the play has its own pace.
When we are doing concerts, we
are doing it at our own pace.
It is my pace.
But a play has its
pace of its own,
and you have to play along
with the pace of the play.
LILLETE DUBEY: And
you're part of a team.
ZILA KHAN: And the
part of the team,
the pace of the play, the
back and forth of dialogues.
And [? now, ?] everybody
helped, including the boys.
And Lillete's way of
explaining direction really
helped me a lot, but I've been
fortunate to have lovely gurus.
My father was an
amazing guru in music.
He used to explain each
and every little thing
and open it out.
And in my acting, this one.
And this, one this gorgeous
one, who I've enjoyed her talk.
And I'm so proud of you.
As an Indian, as a
woman, it's so important
to be associated with a
production as fabulous as this,
and in coming here, and
production as fabulous as--
LILLETE DUBEY:
[INAUDIBLE] She was like--
[LAUGHING] [INAUDIBLE]
OK, no problem.
The music was not,
but I must tell you
that she worked very hard.
You know, what I loved about
her was that, at this age,
where you are so, so respected
and admired in your field,
and you've reached
such a height,
to challenge yourself and
risk all that in a new area,
it needs a lot of
courage, and I love that.
I mean, I love doing new things.
I love doing new things
to keep myself fresh.
People say, what's the
best thing you've done?
What's the best
play you've done?
The best film you've done?
Firstly, the best
thing I've ever done
is produce two children
called Neha and Ira.
Those are my best productions.
ZILA KHAN: I agree.
LILLETE DUBEY: Two best
productions of my life.
Nothing can compare to that.
But after them, there
is nothing the best.
The minute as a creative person
you say, I have done that
and that was my best, go hang
up your sandals and go home.
It's all over.
You are constantly-- the
journey's excitement.
You know, once I've done a play,
I'm thinking of the next play.
I'm thinking of the next
thing I'm going to do.
I mean, I love what I've done.
It's not like I
disassociate myself with it.
But my mind's ticking on
what I'm going to do next.
That next high that
I'm looking for
is when I create the next piece.
Then I struggle and find
it, and get it right,
and then it's never right.
Let me tell you, nothing I've
ever done is, I feel right.
I feel there's so much
that could improved in it.
No role.
People say, what's
your best role?
I say maybe if I had done work
like Sarah Bernhardt, maybe I
[INAUDIBLE].
I would have done something.
I want to do all the male
Shakespeare parts myself
one day, just to
reverse the whole thing.
But--
ZILA KHAN: James Bond, when
Angelina Jolie said, yes, I'd
love to play James Bond myself.
LILLETE DUBEY: Yeah, yeah.
And Sarah Bernard did that.
She was this wonderful
female actress
who played only the male
parts, Hamlet, and Macbeth.
And says, move over.
I'll show you how to do that.
So-- so, you know, to challenge
yourself anew like that,
and then you are like
a child, because you're
coming into an area.
It's like me trying to
become a computer scientist.
I mean, I know nothing.
I become Robert De
Niro, as the intern.
But all those guys in the Google
movie, you know, my friend--
what's his name?
I loved it.
Those two guys.
This ripe old age
coming to like, coming
hang out with the Googlers, and
do their thing and all that.
And not scared.
Not scared.
So that's what she was.
She was a little Googler who
came to a new space completely.
And everybody, obviously,
was more trained
in a sense than her.
But she was not afraid.
She was not afraid to sound like
she didn't know, or anything.
That's a wonderful quality.
I think that's how you grow.
You grow when you keep on
exploring latent things in you.
You know, [INAUDIBLE] leaves
the tech world says, OK,
enough of that.
Let's get on let's get into
something called theater.
Which you might have
done in college,
but this is another animal,
if you know what I mean.
So to keep trying new stuff.
People say, [NON-ENGLISH].
Regrets.
Not regrets, but [NON-ENGLISH].
I said, my gone.
Every year that I
get older, the clock
is ticking louder and
louder and louder.
And I'm saying, heck,
I've got such little time,
I want to write a book.
Maybe cut an album one day.
You know, make some movies.
Do this, do that.
I mean, maybe I'll
do none of it.
But at least the bucket
list is growing that long.
So I think that's what
keeps you, creatively,
the juices flowing, is when
you are not scared to keep
trying things, new things.
And that's one thing about Zila,
is she worked very, very hard,
and she was fearless.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: But I
think as a producer/director,
she was the mos
fearless of the lot.
Because when she called me and
she said, you're doing Gauhar.
I said, wow.
As an actor?
[INAUDIBLE]
She says, do you
sing, I said, yeah,
but I'm not a classical singer.
I was so scared.
And those days, I was
filming for something else.
Every day, I was
to go to the shoot,
and I would be
singing on the way.
[INAUDIBLE] But I don't even
know how to [INAUDIBLE]..
And in the moving cars, I would
OK, [INAUDIBLE],, or something.
So I told her, I
said, I don't know.
Yeah.
So I said, I don't know how good
I will be in the first show.
LILLETE DUBEY: You
were very good.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV:
I don't know how well
I'm going to pull this off.
But I promise you,
by the 30th show,
I'll be standing
there and saying yes,
yes I can do this well.
And maybe I'll get better.
LILLETE DUBEY: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHING]
So I wanted them to do a
small song in which, actually,
they're in costume, and
it's very different,
and it looks stunning.
[INAUDIBLE]
But to do just the
last, one last song,
when it's a beautiful scene
when the two Gauhars, the older
Gauhar dies-- and the play keeps
going back and forth in time.
You know, I mean, not
even chronologically.
1895 to suddenly
1902, back to 1929,
back to this, back to that.
Keeps the audiences nice
and properly on their toes
to figure out what's going.
So all of you who are coming
Sunday, I'm warning you.
So at the end when she dies,
it's in a surreal space,
and the two Gauhars meet,
the young and the old.
So your own 22-year-old
meets, or whatever,
30-year-old, meets
your 59-year-old self.
And we talk a little bit.
So it's that scene at the end,
which is the penultimate scene.
And then there's a little song,
which is one of her most--
when I fell in love with
Gauhar, after I had decided
to [NON-ENGLISH]
singing this song,
which she's going
to sing just now.
And it made my hair rise.
And I said, my god, her
song is still being sung.
And [INAUDIBLE],, of
course, rocked it.
And she was very impressed,
because I went to her
and I said, isn't this
Gauhar Jaan's song?
And she looked at
me, and she said,
my god, I didn't know you know
so much about classical music.
And I said, well, one
knows a little bit.
And then I said I
better bullshit her.
I said, no, no.
Actually, I'm just
doing this play.
[LAUGHING]
I though there was
something here.
You seem too well-acquainted
with all her music.
So I say, yeah, well.
I'm doing her music.
That's how I know it.
So it's a stunning song.
And I would love her to sing it.
I'm not going to-- they
both sing it together.
But because her voice is not OK.
But she dances the
[NON-ENGLISH] with it.
So you get a feel of
the play, and we we're
going to get off the stage now.
ZILA KHAN: So I had learned
Gauhar Jaan's [NON-ENGLISH]
and many thousands of different
kinds of [NON-ENGLISH] from
different [NON-ENGLISH] from
my father since I was a child.
So when this [INAUDIBLE]
came to me, so
it was quite something that
I've already learned from.
And it's one of the most
beautiful pieces of Gauhar's,
and I'm so--
all your pieces that
you have selected
and the songs in
the how of Gauhar
is exceptionally beautiful.
Shall we start?
[INAUDIBLE], are we ready?
So now, there's
just the two of us.
Who was the person you
were hoping to meet here?
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: Ami?
Where is she?
Have you seen her?
ZILA KHAN: She's
right here with us.
[SIGHING]
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV:
She always [INAUDIBLE]..
Here it is.
You have to keep breaking
your heart until it opens.
It's opened.
ZILA KHAN: It's opened.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: Let's
celebrate the way we know best.
With a song.
ZILA KHAN: Not any song,
but the one we love best.
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: That one?
Don't you feel sad singing it?
ZILA KHAN: Not anymore.
[LAUGHING]
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV:
Our sad song.
Let's make it a happy one.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
RAJESHWARI SACHDEV: Thanks.
AKSHAY THAKKER: I want to
bring up one more person.
We have Vinita Belani.
She is a part of EnActe Arts.
She brought this
play and many other--
she brings many other the
productions here to the US.
So let's bring Vinita up on
stage and hear more about.
VINITA BELANI: Thanks.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Hi,
Vinita Could you tell us
a little bit about your
company, and what else is coming
in the pipeline for you here?
VINITA BELANI: Well,
everybody heard Lillete talk.
Everybody understands the
compulsion for theater.
Everybody understands
the importance by now.
If you haven't
understood it, I don't
know anybody who could be
more articulate than Lillete
on the idea.
And just Lillete started her
theatre company years and years
ago, because there was a vacuum,
there were Indian stories were
not being told in English, I
said that I have to confess--
I'm almost embarrassed
to confess this
after Lillete's talk, that
I am a computer scientist.
[LAUGHING]
So I lived in the tech
world for a long time.
I did three start-ups.
EnActe is my fourth startup.
It's very much a
Silicon Valley startup.
We are a talent incubator.
We are bootstrapped
in the garage.
We went through our friends
and family round of funding
and now going to a
series A funding,
which is why Lillete is here.
She's our centerpiece
for our gala on Saturday.
So we are using tech,
as Gauhar used tech,
to change the history of music,
in many ways, in [INAUDIBLE]..
But we are now in the
diaspora of South Asians,
people originally from South
Asian, a significant community.
And we are sitting on
the edge of two cultures,
the culture that--
at least our
children are sitting
on the edge of two
cultures, and we are sort of
cultures, which the culture
that we came from, the
culture that we live in.
So EnActe does a
lot of work which
is layered in
diaspora playwrights.
We are a talent incubator in
all aspects of the theater--
playwrighting, stage management,
acting, music, dance,
performance.
As a female artistic director
of a theater company,
I feel very compelled to
tell the stories of women
who can be strong role
models for our daughters
and for our sons.
We did a play last year
called "Sound Waves," which
is the story of [INAUDIBLE].
She was this young
Muslim girl living
in Paris, daughter of a Sufi
preacher, who joined the World
War II spy movement
because she was
compelled, even as a
pacifist, to do something
to stop the war.
And she got a George Cross.
She was given the
[INAUDIBLE] by France.
Churchill admitted
that she had--
she had reduced the course of
World War II by at least four
to six months, just with her
work in the French resistance
alone.
And even I hadn't heard
about [INAUDIBLE]..
So these are stories
that need to be told.
Vikram Sampath, who wrote the
book "My Name is "Gauhar Jaan,"
is a classmate of mine from
[INAUDIBLE],, also an engineer.
[LAUGHING]
Sometimes we do some
things right, right?
And somebody had
given me his book.
And I said, oh, my gosh.
I wish someone would
write a play about this
so we could do it.
And then we found out that
the play had been written,
and Lillete had done it.
So there you go.
Between this and
there, and "Gauhar"
is a story that
needs to be told.
There are many stories
that need to be told.
But EnActe exists because
our stories are not
being told in the
demographic in which we live.
We are telling them to
our own people-- everybody
here in the Bay
Area, for example,
there is no demographic
majority anymore.
There's a whole
bunch of minorities,
and all these minorities are
practicing their art in silos.
And we are trying to
break these cultural silos
and give our children an
opportunity to grow and develop
their talent.
For every 10 people
who become engineers,
there is that one
11th person that does
want to become an
[INAUDIBLE],, or a [INAUDIBLE]..
So where is the training
ground for these people?
The training ground is EnActe.
And here's my two
wonderful trainees.
We're a talent incubator.
We tell stories from South Asia.
We have a lot of fun doing it.
And we do it in all humility.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Wonderful.
What's coming next to the Bay
Area that you're bringing?
VINITA BELANI: Oh, thank you
for asking that question,
because I'm directing
a play that we
had commissioned by a
Hollywood script writer
called "My Fair Dude."
It's a sort of tongue in
cheek, tongue in cheek,
take on the original
"My Fair Lady" story,
the Pygmalion story.
But it is set right
here in Silicon Valley.
The protagonist is a
young, nerdy engineer,
living and working
in a tech company.
And he's having trouble dating.
And [LAUGHING].
See?
Everybody identifies with this.
And he's having trouble dating
because he hasn't quite got
the social dynamic straight.
And he gets helped
by a girl called
Abby, who is the VP of
technology at his company.
She just happens to be
very lesbian, very bad ass.
And she takes him in hand, and
she finds him a tutor, who is--
and I won't reveal
the rest of it,
because you'll just
have to come and see it.
But that is a story about
people like you, and my kids,
and everybody who's living
here in Silicon Valley in San
Francisco.
It's an out and out
slapstick Broadway
musical, song and dance,
hoohaa kind of play.
We do some of those too.
AKSHAY THAKKER: When
is this scheduled to--
VINITA BELANI: That's
coming up in May.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Excellent.
VINITA BELANI: Before
that, we are doing a play
that we opened in January
in San Francisco called
"The Party," which is a
very intense and a very
gut-wrenching kind
of play, because it's
the story of partition told by
the survivors of partition who
crossed the line on both sides.
AKSHAY THAKKER:
Thank you so much.
Good luck with "Gauhar" and
all your other productions.
VINITA BELANI:
Yes, and thank you
for having Lillete and all of
these wonderful people here.
And thank you for
inviting me as well.
AKSHAY THAKKER: Of course.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]